pivotal game of the national league east
some of the players in fact many of them
wearing the jackie robinson honored
socks
and everybody wearing the number 42 a
tradition that major league baseball has
kept over the years
and it's pretty cool tradition the
right-hander zach wheeler
who's been as good as the phillies could
have wanted him to be john at this point
in the year
he sure has freddie freeman stands in
freddie freeman the game-winning homer
against the yankees the other day not
going this time and freddie a line drive
through the
it hole on the left side they played him
in a shift it's an 11-game hitting
streak
for freddie freeman nobody does that
better than freddie freeman bill's
nothing in the braves nothing we're in
the bottom of the third inning andrew
mccutchen batting with one out and one
on
there he goes punches hit out towards
center field that's smoked
that is gonna be into the bushes a
two-run home run for mccutcheon
and the phillies take a two-nothing lead
i didn't know if that was going to hit
off the brick wall he hit it so hard
darnell wanted that pitch
in on andrew and didn't quite get it
there
jackie robinson patch and shows it some
love two-run home run his third of the
year
and the phillies take a two-nothing lead
now ozuna could tie it up he into a
double play his first time on checks
freeman
and brings it swing and a shot hammered
toward the gap boy that sounded loud and
it was off the base of the wall
freddie freeman is going to come home
and score ozuna on his way to second
back-to-back doubles and the braves have
cut the lead in half that's a perfect
example chip
first pitch up and in kind of backed him
off a little bit threw a good
fastball in you see that i think we both
know there's not a fastball marcel can't
hit if it's out over the plate
the braves have the tying run in scoring
position yes segura up trying to get the
rudder over to third or in either one
it's a center field that's well hit
acuna is going back
toward the fence it is gone
gene segora with some power
straight away center field and the
phillies take a
4-1 lead well there's your answer back
right there
tom give up one get back two did you see
how easy that swing was and and the
power he could generate with an easy
swing he stayed on bound
wanted that distance to be a little bit
more than mccutchen's it was exactly the
same
distance 422. that was a shot bottom
third of the order for the braves here
in the fifth adam duvall grounded out
his first time
as that one's on the ground too bowm at
third nice play
and not in time duvall beats it out good
start
hope he's all right hope he didn't jam a
foot also trying to get on that base
and anytime you see the trainer come out
talk to a man sprinting down the line
you think hamstring your ankle
he's trying i don't know if he stepped
on the bag weird you know he reached out
far
to get there you know the way hoskins
was
in position to catch that ball at first
base i wonder if that's what forced
duvall to make that
awkward move at the very end of his leap
toward the first base bag
he's gonna have to leave the game oh
goodness and here's ozuna the best
marcel could do is make it a one-run
game
as osuno awaits and rips that to the
left side diving stop gregorius
scrambles to his feet
and hoskins can't handle it coming home
to score
is a cuny and the braves get a gift run
it's four to two
great diving stop by didi gregorius but
rhys hoskins
couldn't handle a long hop seemed more
interested in defending his face than
trying to catch
him he did he looked like a guy who'd
never played catch before and the braves
bring the tying run to the plate
meeting him here in the seventh inning
he'll have ender in cirte and austin
reilly
is where the braves have done so much
good work
there's a high fly ball off the bat of
ender that's hit to deep right field
harper goes back that ball
is gone ender in cirte with a lightning
bolt
has just made it a one-run game and
ender in ciarte
has just hit his first home run since
august 11
2019 another run now it's 4-3
now riley unloads a line drive homer
back to back and we're tied back-to-back
home runs
the phillies bullpen and adam morgan had
trouble again tonight
new life for atlanta it's 4-4 with
nobody out
10th inning 4-4 score shane green's back
out there for atlanta after a one two
three night
that's the guy that matters right there
the winning run roman quinn
at third three balls two strikes two
outs the pitch
little chopper hit up the middle
dansby's got it he has to make the throw
to first and green
got out of it unbelievable what a job by
shane greene
two scoreless innings the phillies leave
them loaded and we live to see the
eleven well here is the dani echo
he does wiggle runner goes from first
pitch inside throw to second base on one
hop he is
out at second base braves will no doubt
take a look just to see
oh boy that's close
[Music]
nice job jt five for 12 now throwing
guys out
two outs and kingry's coming up for the
first time line drive out to left field
going back on it is
gone a three-run walk-off home run for
scott
kingry here in the bottom of the 11th
inning down to two strikes
and he let it rip seven for the final
score
mccutchen breakdancing celebration 2020
style